so this is my heartbeat right now life
I'm wearing a heartrate monitor and it's
it's a little bit higher than usual it's
usually around 60 this is fine this is
fine this is fine it's going up yeah
okay
let's put this in perspective for for
for a bit so still going up so last week
I did a conference in Oslo and we had an
amazing trip for the speakers we went to
see the Northern Lights that is me that
was fantastic
but unfortunately on the way back we it
was kind of slippery and our car started
skidding a bit on the road and then we
went almost into a barrier and then we
ended up in a well in the ditch so we
were all right no problem except when I
got back to the hotel I was kind of
curious how high my heartbeat was during
the accidents and it's only around 85 so
this is quite high it's doing this talk
with hardware demos again that is way
scarier than being in a car accident
so we had talks from Stephanie today we
had talked from Sebastian and they all
had hardware demos and they all worked
so by the rules of the demo God's mind
must feel
that there is no way I can fix that but
I'll I'll try to make the good ones work
so I did this talk in England last year
and and none of them worked so right now
we have heart rate monitor that's
actually working so this is already good
so yeh just to prove that it is real
live my heart beat and I'm not just
telling stories I'm gonna take it off
yeah it's fine it's fine
I'm not actually dead but alright so
let's start with the actual talk so this
talk is fun with Bluetooth the first
question you always get is why well
because I'm not really good in to figure
out how USB plugs into computers it
always takes at least three four five
times so I thought I go with wireless
but seriously why so progressive web
apps progressive web apps are great you
get offline support you get an app like
experience yet Add to Home screen and
for many things PW is offer an
equivalent or even a better experience
than native apps but there is one thing
that PW is come do they are bound to
what the browser can do so they're great
for talking to servers on the internet
but not so great for talking to devices
you have at home to do that you need
native apps but I don't want to read I
don't want download the 500 megabyte app
on my phone or the app is really crappy
it was built 10 years ago
or it doesn't work anymore never updated
for the latest version of Android of iOS
or I just want to use my laptop in our
desktop instead of a phone and the
you build a mobile app so there are many
technologies that you can use to talk to
devices USB was one of them that
actually works pretty good but a lot of
other technologies are not suitable for
the web so for example even though Wi-Fi
devices usually expose a web server you
could connect you from a web app they
are often HTTP only and good luck
connecting to that device using HTTPS
only progressive web apps so I could in
theory build a web app for controlling
my you lights because it has a web
server or controlling my sonís because
it has a web server but both will not
work because they are HTTP but there is
one technology out there that's ideal
for devices it's low energy it's cheap
and there are millions of devices
already out there using this technology
so there's now a web app that you can
use to talk to those devices I'm talking
about beauties of course and I know I
know I know the first thing everybody
always says when I start talking about
Bluetooth Bluetooth yeah this sucks it's
slow its limited range sparing it's 20
year old technology based on 20 year old
standards but then you're thinking about
classic Bluetooth that's the reason
everybody is beautiful but beautiful so
energy is actually a modern standard so
it's known under many names like little
smart or Bluetooth le Billy Bluetooth 4
plus 5 if you're worried worried about
range for example the maximum range that
it got little v working is more than a
kilometer between devices and 10 million
devices shipped every single day like
mobile phones computers but also more
practical medical applications like
glucose monitors
they come in blue tooth versions and we
have activity trackers heart rate
monitors in IOT devices like light bulbs
even toys like cute little robots or
drones or fidget spinners or yeah forget
about that one but first first we're
gonna have to talk about the boring
theoretical stuff about Bluetooth itself
and bluetooth is in the web standard so
things are a little bit different so
when we're talking about duty devices we
have central devices and we have
peripherals a central device can talk to
a peripheral or can't connect to a
peripheral but a peripheral can't
connect to a central device so it's one
way for connecting and then you can
exchange data a central device can
connect to multiple peripherals at the
same time but the peripherals among
themselves can't talk to each other they
could relay messages using the central
device but that is something you have to
write yourself and we're not talking
about just beautiful eyes in general
we're talking about a very specific
profile called generic attribute profile
and it has a very obvious creation G ATT
because apparently GA peel is already
taken and now we're no longer talking
about central devices and peripherals
we're talking about clients and servers
so your our light bulb is a server yeah
but if you think about it kind of makes
sense because the lightbulb offers a
surface light so it is a server clients
well just like your browser is a client
talks to servers on the Internet the
clients your progressive web app or your
native app on your phone talks to the
server in light bulb so a light bulb
offers services one of them is light of
course that is not a standard service
but there are also standard services
specified by the beauty specification
like device information which tells you
manufacturer or model or and so on so
drone might have again device
information and battery information
because drones run on batteries and you
might want to know when the battery dies
and we have flight control the cute
little robot has device information
battery again and steering control and
device information battery are standards
but steering control and flight control
were not standards so that differs
between manufacturer and even models
sometimes so the heart rate monitor well
that has device information battery and
heart rates which is a standard but of
course if you buy a cheap one it's not
gonna have device information not gonna
have battery service and the heart rate
is something they just invent them
themselves so this can get a bit tricky
little bit more expensive one does have
all the standard services if you look at
one of those standard services you're
gonna have characteristics inside of
them
a characteristic is one property of that
device information or a property of that
service and we can have multiple
characteristics for each service so we
can have manufacturer we can have model
number serial number and so on and each
of these characteristics can have values
so it's kind of like
the server is kind of like an array of
objects and the service is an object in
that array the characteristic is cannot
a property of that object and they have
a value kind is similar it's not that
simple but basically it come down to
this and we know how do we work with
objects and arrays and properties and
values so this is basically the same
thing only it's a bit more verbose and
you have to write more code to do it so
services and characteristics are
identified by uu IDs and they are 16-bit
or 128 bits and they look like this so
device information is 188 and battery is
one on ITF and your light switch isn't a
standard doesn't have a fixed UID they
had to choose that themselves and it can
differ between manufacturer and model
now they must seer out of the standard
range but nobody does this so everybody
uses a 16-bit UID and there may be some
collisions there so instead of looking
like this
it actually looks like this so this is
really bad for readability and figure
out how things work it's actually very
good for Bluetooth itself because little
has low bandwidth and sending just
numbers is easier than sending a
complete strings so if you have one of
those characteristics you can read from
them you can write to them they can get
notified of changes and every value is
an array of bytes they're no fancy
datatypes it just bytes so a few
that was the boring part so how does
this look so I have an app on my phone
and I can actually connect to a device I
can inspect all the characteristics and
all the services so I connect it to a
light bulb and there are a proper couple
of services like device information and
there is battery service and the level
is at ninety percent fine but there is
also custom a number of custom services
with a lot of characteristics I don't
know what each of those do but I'm
particularly interested in one of them
the top one that is 4 bytes so what if I
change one of those bytes for example if
I change the value to 0 0 ff0000
then light bulb turns red interesting so
what if I change it to 0 0 0 0 FF 0 0 it
turns green let's try 0 0 0 0 0 0 FF it
turns blue
yeah it turns blue so these are RGB
values we can make basically every color
but what if you change the first bytes
what happens then
FF 0 0 0 0 0 0 it turns white so there
are 4 LEDs in this light bulb and each
of those LEDs can be controlled by one
byte by one can change the intensity of
each of these LEDs by changing the value
of that byte so this is really close to
what we know like colors in HTML and
JavaScript so this this is this is good
so this has been boring facts about
Bluetooth yeah so now it's time for fun
mellitus finally finally
but first the API I have to talk a bit
about the API that is actually in
browsers so we need to be able to
connect to a device and to do that we
need to call a function called navigator
dot Bluetooth dot request device similar
to what Sebastian explained with WebP
USB and we provide a couple of filters
to make sure we can connect to the right
device because we don't want to list all
the Bluetooth devices that this there
are way too many and we specify which
services we're going to use so when we
execute this function a dialog box pops
up and all the devices that conform to
the filters we set will be less there
and now the actual the user has to
physically on the computer collect the
device and pair with it so this this is
security because we don't want to have
our browser just sniffing all the
devices in our network is connected to a
light bulb and and turning lights on and
off but because so many thought that was
funny
so once the user clicks on the pair
button we get a property of a promise
back and that with that promise we can
actually get to the data but promises
are so 2017 we now have a single wait
and that works even better so we can
await request device and we get the
device and then we can wait connecting
to the GA TT server and get the server
and then we can await getting the
primary service which is specified by
the UUID and we get a service and
finally we get the characteristics again
specified by their UUID and we get the
characteristic and now we have the
characteristic and we can actually start
doing stuff with it like writing data so
you call
right value on the characteristic with
those bytes and in case of a lightbulb
it's just four bytes so we can specify
an RGB value and for reading data we can
just call read value on the
characteristic and away that and we get
a value and we can pull out those
individual bytes again and I mentioned
getting notified of changes that is also
possible and for a light bulb that isn't
really useful but if you wear a heart
rate monitor for example now that's
really useful because I want to know
when the heart rate changes so I can
update it on the screen so it's kind of
like addeventlistener
no it actually is add eventlistener with
the value characteristic value changed
and we have a callback and we can get to
the data again but we must not forget to
actually start notifications because
otherwise it won't work because
bandwidth again is limited and we don't
want to flood the network with necessary
packets with all the data unless we
actually want it so the things you need
to know is the web Bluetooth API which
the I pretty much explained to you in
the last twenty minutes and that's about
90% of the API so all of the the demos I
I created are all using what I showed
you and we need to know promises of
course or async awake and types arrays
and those are now standard JavaScript
features so before we go on we need to
talk a bit about well browser supports
so right now it's supported in Chrome
it's supporting opera is supported in
Samsung internet on Android phones and
it is in servo built kind of what the
hell what is developed in servo it's
kinda like a development platform for
for Firefox it tend to end up in Firefox
so that is a good thing
and it works in iOS well not not in
Safari but there is a browser on iOS
called web Billy that supports this API
and it's supported in electronics for
even nodes with a package node web
Bluetooth it's supported in Cordova if
you still use that and it's supported by
s Perino which is really interesting
because SP we know is in JavaScript
interpreter that runs on
microcontrollers really really small
microcontrollers you can build your own
stuff with this so I did encounter some
issues I mentioned that's not all
characteristic first standardized so I
did buy I bought a whole box of
Bluetooth LED bulbs this is the most
sane one we've already gone over this
this is just four bytes it's really
simple but some of them are not this
simple it's still not that bad but for
example this one it has five bytes so we
have RGB and then two more and for every
color there is a switch to turn it on
and off and the order for RGB is really
unconventional because it's gbr I don't
know half and why would you need
switches because we if you set the
intensity to zero it's already turned
off yeah so it's simple so this light
bulb is a little bit more difficult it's
every single byte has to be exactly like
this otherwise it won't work and there
has to be a random number in there
because no two messages can be the same
then you have to calculate the checksum
because butit doesn't do that well of
course it does but but well we'll just
do it again yeah but this is this is
okay so I also brought this little LED
matrix this is basically sixty-four
light bulbs sixty-four LEDs you can turn
change the color of each of these LEDs
by changing well sending a message with
the position which one are we going to
change an accord it's kind of pretty
much the same as a light bulb so this is
really simple but I also have another
one and that is a little bit more
difficult this this is still pretty okay
but we had to have to add some extra
code and some more codes and yeah this
is just to change one of those LEDs so
you're probably not gonna figure this
out just by looking at the actual values
so you need to actually help so what you
can do is sniff the Bluetooth Network
and actually look at the packets that
are being sent from the native app to
your device
and it sounds really bad and it is
because that means there is no security
so they fix that this only works for
Bluetooth 4.0 for all our device of a
newer devices this won't work but they
are still possible to get to that same
data by using an Android phone and turn
on Bluetooth logging and you can use ADB
to transfer that to your computer and
then you can look at it with Wireshark
and you can actually see the bytes that
are being generated by the native app
and you could mimic that but some of the
devices I looked into were well even too
complicated for that so it is possible
please don't tell anybody it is possible
to decompile apks and look at the source
code and get inspired by it
let's call it inspires yeah inspired um
that works really well but don't don't
tell anybody so now it's time for
finally for the fun part
but I have to give a warning because
it's still experimental technology
things will probably go wrong I just
hope it's gonna be the bad demos and not
the good demos and well it works at home
because at home I don't have Wi-Fi
interference and on the conference there
are so many people with Wi-Fi devices
and they use the same frequency as
little so it's yeah
so let's let's just get on with it
so first I need to do this alright so
let's take a deep breath here we go I'm
gonna change the colors of a light bulb
and I can't connect to this light bulb
by clicking the connect button bearing
with it and clicking a color and
immediately the light bulb changes color
so there's nothing in between it's just
from the browser straight to the light
bulb by sending those four bytes now if
it changed the bytes I'm sending it
turns green or blue yellow black yeah
that doesn't work rats
so what else can we do with this oh I
could use CSS purple or
Navy kind of feels too simple you know
what
let's try CSS animations so we have CSS
animations running on a light bulb yeah
I thought this was really cool but it is
actually kind of cheating because the
C's CSS animation is running in a
browser and I just pick out the colors
from the browser and send it to the
light bulb so it's kind of like cheating
but it's still pretty cool so what else
do we got what I brought the matrix and
I'll quickly do a little demo with that
it's gonna be really hard to see
especially from from up there
I like to procrastinate and by drawing
cute little monsters
like this it's just fun but I also
brought something else and to show this
I'm gonna need to clear up this table a
bit put this down
I brought a Lego car and this usually
has an infrared range we receive but I
changed it into a Bluetooth receiver
which you can also buy in a store but
not from Lego it's a third party and
then you can connect to it and you can
actually start start driving it so this
table is really small so this is
actually really dangerous
my four-year-old son would never forgive
me if I crashed the thing and it
wouldn't work in here it's just so what
else can we do with this we had CSS
animation on the light bulb could we use
CSS animations on this yeah so I
prepared something and I have a keyframe
or our keyframes
it's called track and uses years
variables for directions and it is left
right left right forward refers I'm
gonna change that not gonna do the
forwards in research reverses here let's
quickly change that so if I enable this
animation it's gonna start driving by
itself hopefully nothing to stuff I put
there yeah
the self-driving car let's try something
else
I also brought a Lego head with me and
inside of that hat is a device called a
Nordic thing that's actually a device
that has a lot of sensors like a
gyroscope but also temperature and air
quality and and so on and if I calibrate
it a bit I can now pick it up and let's
follow the movements I make so basically
I use the gyroscope to figure out the
position inside of the head and
translate that to something from there
and translate that into what WebGL
transforms and we could use this to well
we could use that to control the car so
I'm going to connect to the second
device now so I've made connections to
two different devices from the same page
now if I
oh this this is gonna end badly all
right so I always tell my for your son
that I'm gonna be careful but if I crash
you can always fix it again that that's
the beauty of Legos so I'm gonna put it
on the ground now and if you have a
recent Android phone you can go to this
URL and connect to the device and the
first one that does this has control
over the car straight from the browser
on your phone to the car
in the meantime I'm gonna gonna do a
quick demo with a receipt printer and
Sebastian already showed a receipt
printer so the receipt printer is not an
USB printer but it's a beautiful inter I
kind of wrote a driver for it because it
supports printer language called EC POS
which is almost 30 years old so I
basically wrote the printer driver and
now when somebody tweets about duckfist
it's gonna print that tweet on the
printer just gonna leave it on because
well my time is almost up well that's
not true I'll have some time to do
something else
I also brought with me an esper we know
it works an s premium microcontroller it
is really tiny it's just less than 2
centimeters by 1 centimeter and it has a
Bluetooth chip by Nordic semiconductors
and this is not distracting at all and
that Bluetooth chip is fast enough to
run JavaScript so I'm gonna connect it
to a battery and then nothing happens
that is supposed to happen
so I have the Esprit new IDE here and
then I can connect to this device there
it is
now once I'm connected I can write Java
scripts and push it to the device now
already build a little application it's
less than 80 lines of code and it
basically sets device up to advertise as
a light bulb and it offers these
services and they may seem familiar
because they are the same services as
this light bulb and I make sure the
characteristic is readable and can make
it right able and use those bytes and
set the color and then I make the colors
sparkle so I change the colors randomly
a bit and it turns on LEDs off and then
we have like a candle effect so it's
just a lines of code gonna upload that
opinion to the device and then it works
just by writing 80 lines of code we
created a light bulb just that that's
just amazing to me so what we could do
with this is we can try to put it away
for all the stuff is gonna work because
there isn't room enough just put it like
this so we have our Bluetooth connected
JavaScript running candle I'll
disconnect now who is doing that
somebody connected to the yeah so let's
try to change this color that works we
can run CSS animations on it again whoa
CSS animations on a candle yeah so I'll
leave this on and I'll leave this on and
now I have well just one more demo well
so I mentioned drones right I brought
one with me but this is really dangerous
so I have to wear safety goggles and
those safety dog goggles are also
bluetooth connected so I'll just put
them on warning danger actually it is
really cool because I can also use this
to visualize audio so every time I speak
just equalizer shows my voice and it
really works
so danger danger
actually I can't see anything with this
class so I'll just put it off but the
drone so this is usually the the most
dangerous sports and sometimes it
doesn't work takes a little while to
build up so when I first tried this at
home I killed some plants my wife wasn't
that happy about it
and there's a little lego guy on top and
he almost got decapitated so it's kind
of tricky it doesn't connect let's see
let's see if can fix that
there is all right you may notice there
is this big red button there called
emergency it's there for a reason so if
I start flying and I inadvertently fly
into the audience I press that red
button and then it will drop down on top
of you well at least the motors won't be
spinning so that's a good thing
so let's put that here somewhere safely
let's see if it works please don't drive
into me let's try again
there it goes
so we can go a little bit further up
safer for me um it's pretty stable let's
why
[Music]
not into the wall this is really hard to
see
no the other way so there's a trick I
can do
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's just land
[Music]
so everything I showed you that was just
straight from the browser to the device
and to me that is just amazing that that
is possible at all nowadays and if
you're interested in this the
manufacturer of the Nordic thingy gave
me a couple of things to give to people
who want to build something their own so
this is just basically a sensory device
it has a gyroscope like I used in the
demo but all kinds of other devices it
has an LED and you can play with it
using progressive web app that they
built but you can also build or connect
with yourself and build something
yourself and as a bonus you can flash
this to an esper we know so you can
actually run javascript on it so if you
want one i only have three with me if
you want one come up to me the first
three are gonna get one so that's it for
me this well this is fun but it also has
really practical and useful applications
and what your imagination is basically
what's stopping this from being an
awesome technology thank you all
you